[Music]
all month long we've been celebrating
women's history month by talking with
female leaders in sports politics
business and
entertainment and this morning we're
focusing on professional athletes
balancing their careers and motherhood
dawn harper nelson is a two-time olympic
track and field medalist who is
setting her sights on the tokyo games
this summer back in 2018
she left the sport to start a family
giving birth to her daughter
harper now she's back coming out of
retirement to compete but the journey
has not been easy here's her story in
her own words
my name is dawn harper nelson and i am a
gold and silver medalist in the 100
meter hurdles
i always say that when i hurdle it's
like poetry in motion it is a gift that
i truly believe god has given me
i've always known that i wanted to have
a family be a wife and a mom
there was really no help and no backing
to say
i want to be a mom and continue to run
track and field
i did not think that i would ever run
again when i made the decision to have a
child
but i remember when i was pregnant i had
a moment where i said
when my child sees these interviews i
don't want her to say
did you give up on everything you were
dreaming of for me
i made the decision to come back and the
fact that i realized
i can have both that was the most
freeing feeling in the world to realize
i didn't have to sacrifice
the blessing is having my husband as my
coach and actually taking off
kind of that weight and that barrier
that i was putting on myself
when i would think of am i being a good
mom right now
absolutely i still deal with questions i
still deal with companies
literally saying prove yourself first
and then we will consider
working with you don't tell me what i
can and cannot do you don't know me and
you don't know my body and i knew what
it took to get on the podium before
and i know what it takes now
having my daughter on the track with me
has been a true balance
you are the reason why mommy realized
she doesn't have to decide
[Music]
dawn harper nelson was able to find
support through the non-profit
and mother it's a great name it offers
grants to female athletes
that help with training travel and
family support